Pussycat Dolls founder Robin Antin slams
kaya Joneses claim that the group was a
prostitution ring it's crazy
[Music]
on Friday the singer made shocking
claims about the girl group in a series
of tweets writing in part quote my truth
I wasn't in a girl group I was in a
prostitution ring the 33 year old added
quote how bad was it
people asked bad enough that I walked
away from my dreams band mates and a 13
million dollar record deal
now Anton is speaking out in defense of
the group she started in 2003 claiming
in a statement to ET on Monday that all
of Jones's allegations are lies quote
Chaya Jones was never a member of the
Pussycat Dolls but simply a pussycat
reject who's looking for her 15 minutes
of fame
Anton added quote I am shocked with the
allegations miss Jones has stated and
they are nothing more than disgusting
ridiculous lies a source close to Anton
tells ET quotes her mission with the
Pussycat Dolls for the last two decades
has always been to nurture and promote
powerful confident women a sentiment
Anton and former Pussycat Doll member
Nicole Scherzinger echoed to ET in June
we always say inside every woman is
missing
[Music]
behind the dolls it's done for us and
while Anton says that jones's
allegations are untrue including her
tweets that being a quote team player in
the group meant to quote sleep with
whoever they say Jones insists she's
telling the truth
quote to the dolls that stayed an
artists I've worked with who knew and
know the truth speak up
[Music]
you